brought to you by the PlayStation
original series powers watch the series
premiere for free on March 10th at
playstation com hey guys this is the
second of moss today my name is Jessa
McDonald and you're watching games
buddies if you're a fan of countdown
clocks in lieu of actual announcements
do I have the story for you Kaname has
posted up a 48 hour countdown clock on
its metal gear solid 5 website
indicating that I'll have some real news
for you in like 13 hours from now pinal
though we're all in the dark as to what
the announcement may be but people have
been guessing that they could be
announcing the official release date all
we know thus far is that the phantom
pain is coming this year the countdown
timer will finish on Tuesday March third
at six a.m. pacific time in things that
are cool Unreal Engine 4 is now free for
everybody thanks to move from its crater
Epic Games sounder Tim Sweeney has said
if you love something set it free and
epic only succeeds when creators succeed
this change comes after last year's news
that Unreal Engine would be accessible
only through a subscription-based model
anyone who paid for that subscription is
now being given a refund and thirty
dollars of credit in the Unreal Engine
marketplace if projects created through
the tool are released commercially
you'll need to pay epic a five percent
royalty on gross earnings but other than
that the company are happy for you to
use the full version for free as much as
you want Sweeney has said whatever your
development aspirations epic stands with
you both ethic technology provider and
as a fellow game developer counting on
you e for to power our own games finally
well the warcraft is getting a
free-to-play option well sort of
Blizzard have enabled a system where
players can buy time in the game
in-game gold they've introduced tokens
which are purchased with real money and
can then be sold in the auction house
these tokens can then be bought from the
auction house with wow gold and are
redeemable for 30 days of game time this
is finally away for time poor games to a
map in-game gold without resorting to
sketchy third-party sites and those with
hordes of gold can put that to good use
fine game time without spending a real
world dollar tokens will be bought
outright that means no bidding and
sellers will be quoted a sale price
based on current supply and demand in
order to prevent tactical buying and
selling once a token is sold it becomes
soul bound and permanently attached to
the fire let me know if you think this
token system is a good idea or not and
why you can head to gamespot well we've
got more details on gamestop accepting
ps2 trade-ins and battlefield hardline
detail that is it from me today I have a
bunch more news the same time tomorrow
but be sure to have a good one until
then